chère maman j'ai été pas mal stressé ces
derniers temps au boulot alors j'ai
décidé de prendre ses vacances au
mexique que j'avais prévu mais en dépit
de ce que les gens disent les rencontres
est absolument aucune difficulté pour
traverser la frontière
à recommander un hébergement sympa j'ai
fait des supers photo
d'activité avec les gens du coin
il dit
tu sais comment c'est
tchimou même si tu cherchais pas à
déclaté
de mon fric
problèmes apparaissent comme
alors fait je les appelle montrant peu à
lui une chose en entraîne une autre
papa précis
viendront chercher oui mais on fera en
sorte que ça n'arrive pas
je veux qu'on voyage se passe bien je
dois écrasé ce truc dans l'oeuf
non non pressé de rentrer
non je rigole
le nouvel pas rentrer
à